as you know we like to respond to
questions from our viewers and recently
we got an email from one of our viewers
a 16 year old young woman in Norway
called Isabel and Isabel has a three and
a half year old black rabbit which he
calls buckyball buckyball as who knows
the name of the molecule c60 and she
sometimes calls it C 64 short buckyball
is a female rabbit and she's expecting
babies and the babies are due really
quite soon and isabel has asked us if
the viewers can choose some suitable
chemically related names for the new
babies there may be up to 8 little
rabbits there may be black they may be
grey because the father is a grey hair
please send in your suggestions either
in the comments below or on I emails I
should say that she's already chosen the
name for the first rabbit she's going to
call it Neal but the other 7 are still
up for grabs
send in your suggestions we'll let you
know which ones Isabelle has chosen and
we'll post some photos of the baby
rabbits when they're born